nous passons maintenant à notre partie
magazine qui sera cette semaine
internationale et culinaire
international parce que nous allons
chercher à savoir comment dans
différents pays
on célèbre le passage d'une année à
l'autre d'ailleurs vous le savez ce
n'est pas forcément toujours le 31
décembre que cela se passe
cela dépend des religions et des
coutumes et puis ce sera d'autre part
une émission culinaire
parce que un peu partout dans le monde
les fêtes sont presque toujours synonyme
de cuisine et puisque nous sommes de
fait vous savez que les français se
rencontrent souvent autour d'une grande
table donc nous allons vous suggérer
avec cuba grégoire quelques plats
originaux que vous pourrez faire à vos
amis à votre famille à chaque fois y
aura bien sûr nous avons choisi des
recettes faciles ultra ultra flashy pull
rfr moi même
c'est vous dire que le vraiment ces
recettes sont faciles et c'est avec
l'angleterre que nous allons ouvrir le
feu madame l'anglais vous allez donc
tiré la première comme disaient nos
ancêtres pour toi c'est bien ça donc
vous êtes anglais à moitié française
vous êtes né en angleterre dans le clip
de l'enduit africains de londres dans un
londres
en décembre j'étais très noël pour
enfants il pas le 26 décembre non non
non non non non mais je suis venu en
avant et puis oui à la wii aura beau
jouer en angleterre
telle est la grande fête de famille est
venue l essentiel nous voulons en cdo
des onglets sont très aimée hermétique
et familiale alors je dirais que ça
serait plutôt noël qui est fêté le plus
la bière a lancé le nouvel ans c'est
plutôt à trafalgar square où en sont
restées de se faire écraser par les gens
ivres et c'est assez paniquons comme
événement mais où les partis chez les
gens mais on voit beaucoup moins le côté
gai et fêtant comme dans les rues à
paris où les gens s'embrassent les gens
sont gentils et marin vous s'est frotté
leurs enfants fait le tout me semble une
bonne réponse est non mais ça me semble
beaucoup beaucoup plus zen ils sont
l'anglais car déjà c'est un peu sinistre
savoir qu'il faut faire la fête mais il
vaut mieux le faire parce que de le
bouder c'est peut-être le couple et
cynisme je sais pas enfoncer plus gai
mais en angleterre c'est le moment j'ai
la caméra peut voir ça c'est christmas
pudding ça c'est que c'est ce que dit
mais moi j'ai une bonne chose à faire
avec ça voulait que je joue vivre alors
ça il faut le bouillir ou l'acheter
c'est beaucoup mieux sinon il faut que
sa main en jeu pendant au moins six ans
c'est pas la peine
alors vous l'achetez et puis vous mettez
des pièces un franc a apparemment
bouillie dedans comme ça les enfants
cassent les dents
il faut valeur agents de précédents
c'est excitant pour va qui a départ avec
de l'argent dedans et puis ça il faut le
servir après 4 3 heures de cuisson
c'est comme ça que tout ça c'est que
marc lépine et puis servi avec sa donc
très chaud et arrosé à la dernière
minute de cognac flamber alors c'est
très joli vous éteignez les lumières et
tout le monde applaudit ce dans le hand
chose bêta et puis avec ça vous fait du
blanc du batteur ça c'est un beurre de
cognin vous mélanger aux parts égales
sucré beurre battus ensemble battu blanc
et puis vous ajoutez une demi bouteille
de cognac d'état gouttes et avec un
mixeur sinon les ampoules ces terrains
mais ça c'est génial vous manger ça très
très franc avec sa très très chaud et
tout le monde est gay mais leur joie qui
a du cognac ces français comme c'est un
plat de l'entente cordiale presque
exactement mais lionel rivoire elle ne
sait pas faire le pudding c'est trop
qu'elle a vendu mine sans lien on
l'achète aussi parce que c'est très très
difficile à faire vous allez en
expliquant c'est une véritable anglaise
qui fait aussi la recette du minispace
s'appelle jennifer et je vous propose de
la suivre et elle va nous donner les
explications justement comment faire ce
minispace pour faire les mines ce pas il
faut des raisins de corinthe des raisins
secs des écorces d'orange et de citron
confit des pommes inciteront de la
graisse de boeuf du sucre des cuirs et
de gingembre de muscade et de canal il
pensait de salles et un verre de cognac
on est là
oh mais aussi tous les ingrédients les
revend les raisins de corinthe les
fruits confits
alors ce sont les écorces sont des
écorces d'orange et de citron quand je
veux tâche si tout préparé comme ça mais
moi j'ai confiance en plus petit je
rends fou le cest d'un citron montauban
et ensuite je coupe le citron je prends
jus je prends du jus que j'ai déjà
pressé je mets tout le jus d'un citron
là dedans je mélange bien
on ajoute me sucre seront toujours qu'on
cite la graisse de boeuf ou que j'ai
râpé et ça surtout il faut bien mélanger
pourquoi se répartit très très bien la
moitié d'une cuillère et le muscat ce2
kaleme et de gingembre
non j'aime en jambes que le parti d'une
crierait je mélange comme toujours
et puis ensuite le maire de cognac
ça dépend dit qu on peut donc plus ou
moins un grand ou un petit verre ou même
dur mais on préfère voilà je mélange
dessous et puis je laisse reposer une
wii en courant avec un torchon comme ça
après deux semaines entre s'en servir
faire une pâte brisée la découper en
rondelles et la placer dans des petits
moules
je vais
ciao un couvercle et je veux avec de
l'eau pour que ça colle bien alors je
pense pour bien scellé je fais des
petits trous pour claire jour sortent
pendant la cuisson et puis un petit peu
2e et les partis ensemble pour que ce
soit bien doré vous mettez dans un four
chaud rien ou 6 environ pendant 20
minutes
voilà vos mines ce pagne sortie du four
et si vous voulez pour les fêtes vous
pouvez l'écrire
quel est le secret d'un gène braf une
gamine spy who vous avez ça vous a plu
oui je vais essayer moi aussi alors je
le fais un petit tas weight recouverte
d'un couvercle et puis et dans lequel il
y en a 1000 à chauffer un chose que
celui ci n'en du parquet du mans n'avait
compris en garde jean louis mais la
recette si on veut la faire jouer c'est
facile car oui c'est facile parce que
vous pouvez nous écrire
on vous donnera la recette ces quatre
communes je vis si vous n'avez pas
compris les obligations de jennifer qui
sont pour moi très clair avec son tour
digne de gestion soit je vais vous poser
une question est ce que les anglais ne
sont pas pris très au sérieux sur le
plan gastronomique mercus et les
actrices tout est-ce que ça les chagrine
pas ce que c'est les touristes anglais
partout ils cherchent nataf tété leur
sandwich dans n'importe quel pays où ils
se trouvent alors capté c'est toute
l'île de france
mais moi en espagne au lieu d'essayer
des choses local qu'ils ont peur que ça
va les donner mais moyennement
épouvantable alors que les français
pensent pareil quand il arrive en
angleterre et il voit avec frayeur les
sectes au cui aidé des affaires anglaise
pour ça c'est tout le monde un peu
racistes sur les cuisines des 11 mai les
anglais quand même sens un peu plus
humble vis à vis de de votre art
culinaire nous y pas l'un c'est une
cuisine traditionnelle qui est très bon
mais parce qu'il ya beaucoup de plats
mijotés où beaucoup de préparation à
l'avancé une chose que vous pouvez faire
cependant une jambe de porc le frottez
avec du avec du de l'huile et du sel et
vous me masser comme si c'était
quelqu'un et puis vous devrez y est
comme ça vous le mettez dans le fourgon
entre 1 heure et après parce qu'il faut
que ça soit très près cuir rôti de porc
et après vous servez ça avec les gelées
de crouseilles et des ses délicieux
oblige les gens quand il s'agit toujours
le même sens minable c'est très bon et
c'est plus que de la nouvelle cuisine
voilà donc c'était une facette un petit
peu inconnu de votre personnage